from sewing people together to chomping
down on a live octopus these R-rated
movies really pushed audiences to their
limits Wolf Creek is the product of
unchecked misogyny and a sickening
fascination with violence the movie
positions itself as a typical slosher
flick about three friends taking a trip
through the Australian Outback when
their car breaks down in Wolf Creek Park
a man named mix stumbles upon the group
and offers to help before revealing
himself to be a sadistic killer that's
not a moment
this
is a knife the trio of protagonists in
Wolf Creek contains one man but he's
sidelined for almost the entirety of the
movie until he escapes with his life at
the end most of the screen time is
dedicated to showing Mick torturing the
two women in ways that the film seems to
find entertaining after an implied
sexual assault mix severs Limbs and
spinal cords while stabbing and shooting
to his heart's content the movie never
lets up on showing women in horrendous
pain and suffering Roger Ebert
rightfully called out the film for its
misogyny writing there is a role for
violence and film but what the hell is
the purpose of this sadistic celebration
of pain and cruelty slashers have their
place but they don't have to be as
openly hateful as Wolf Creek
unfortunately the visceral nature of
these killings might be due to the movie
being based on a true story that of Ivan
milact the serial killer known as The
Backpacker murderer a movie with a title
like I Spit on Your Grave sets a certain
tone for audiences before they even walk
into the theater the film debuted in
1978 with a poster that read this woman
has just cut chopped broken and burned
five men beyond recognition but no jury
in America would ever convict her aside
from the dubious Claim about juries the
sentence perfectly sums up the film's
fascination with violence unfortunately
violence is really the only thing this
movie cares to show the premise sees a
woman seeking revenge on five men after
they sexually assault her and the weak
plot nearly serves as a means to string
together one horrifying scene after
another the assault that kicks off the
movie's Revenge plot takes up gratuitous
amounts of screen time and the brutal
murders that follow it don't really
offer any sense of catharsis Roger Ebert
called the movie a vile bag of garbage
and continued by saying attending it was
one of the most depressing experiences
of my life the shock Factor can carry a
movie pretty far though decades after
its release I Spit on Your Grave somehow
spawned a 2010 remake and multiple
sequels each arguably as upsetting as
the original
sausage party the 2016 comedy from the
minds of Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
begins with the premise reminiscent of
Toy Story when the lights go out at a
local grocery store the food items come
alive most of them dream of one day
being bought by a customer and taken to
the great beyond but they don't realize
they're destined to be eaten alive
feature-length adult animation with an
imaginative concept seems like a
promising proposition on release the
movie generated a ton of Buzz and its
critical reception was overwhelmingly
positive Looking Back Now it's hard to
imagine how the film even earned a
release much less critical praise
considering how heavily it relies on
being downright offensive for Laughs the
crude sexual humor is rampant but with a
name like sausage party what else would
you expect you couldn't fit an eggplant
in there it's too big it'll tear you in
half however what's really jarring is
just how many racial stereotypes were
squeezed into the film scene after scene
pairs cream Abdul lavash with Sammy
Junior and forces them to play out one
anti-muslim or anti-semitic Trope after
another Ascension bottle of Native
American liquor is given a cringe-worthy
performance by Bill Hader and the
movie's Twinkie character is gay the
list of groups used as punch lines goes
on and on but the movie really should
not
Bucky Larson born to be a star really
tries its hardest to turn the adult film
industry into one interminable running
joke but it really should have channeled
its efforts elsewhere the film follows
its titular character after he discovers
that his parents used to be porn stars
Bucky takes their history as inspiration
and sets off for Hollywood determined to
find his own way to break into the
industry
my destiny I was born to be a star it
doesn't take long for Bucky to realize
that his body doesn't exactly live up to
adult film standards but he finds his
way to stardom despite anything that
he's lacking the problem with Bucky
Larson might not be that it went too far
with its lazy sex humor but that it
didn't go far enough with creating real
characters or a story worth paying
attention to there are only so many
small penis jokes someone can be
expected to listen to and Bucky Larson
fills out more than a lifetime's quota
Darren Aronofsky has become synonymous
with films that push boundaries he isn't
afraid to tell complicated stories or to
present audiences with horrifying
imagery that works to make the reality
of his characters really hit home it's a
filmmaking strategy that's definitely
earned him success but one that's also
sure to turn away plenty of viewers
Requiem fur dream was aronofsky's second
film and he had ambitious plans for it
the movie is an adaptation of a Hubert
Selby Jr novel and the story centers on
the lives of a group of addicts living
in New York City Sarah becomes addicted
to amphetamines while trying to lose
weight for a potential television
appearance while her son Harry and his
friends use and deal heroin the film
uses split screen segments and other
editing techniques to disorient
audiences and put them in the mindset of
the movie's fractured characters the
bizarre and Rapid editing is enough to
make someone feel a bit queasy in
certain moments but it's the movie's
depiction of needle injections arm
infections violence and sexual assault
that really takes things over the top
the original cut of the the film was
rated NC-17 but even though the R-rated
version cut down on some of the sexual
content the rest is still graphic enough
to sicken an unprepared viewer Oldboy is
the 2003 South Korean film by director
Park Chan wuk based on the Japanese
manga of the same name the movie follows
the man named odessu who's kidnapped and
locked inside what amounts to a hotel
room for 15 years when he suddenly
released odessu desperately begins
looking for the truth behind his
imprisonment and plotting revenge
against the people who took him captive
by any measure old boy is a fantastic
film it delivers a noir-styled story
with some truly memorable fight scenes
and a plot that keeps you guessing right
up to the very end however critical
Acclaim and popular reception aside the
movie still goes too far at least once
some might find the big twist a bit on
the growth side but that's not the gross
out moment that puts old boy over the
top the octopus eating scene takes place
shortly after odessu is released from
his prison he shows up at a sushi
restaurant and demands to eat something
that's still alive he proceeds to Chow
Down on a live octopus which lead actor
Troy Min sick really did creating the
scene took three takes and each time in
sick crushed a live octopus between his
teeth does the scene create a
thematically resonant moment in the
movie sure was it completely necessary
almost definitely not the very premise
of 2009's The Human Centipede takes
things so far that it's a wonder that
the movie ever got made for anyone who's
missed more than a decade's worth of
jokes about the film here's a basic
breakdown of the plot Dr Joseph heider
is a retired surgeon turned psychopath
who's become obsessed with using his
medical skills to make obscene creatures
he kidnaps three tourists and sews them
together in a line to form one
continuous digestive tract after that
Eider spends the rest of the movie
continuing to torment the three as he
trains his Human Centipede as a pet
eventually investigators stumble upon
heider's home and the bloodbath brings
the movie to its conclusion The Human
Centipede is nauseating to even think
about and watching it is no better as
we've already seen with other movies on
this list though nausea inducing shocks
can take a movie pretty far horror
movies often aim to make audiences
uncomfortable but it's a thin line
between scaring an audience so badly
they hide their eyes and showing them
something so repulsive they're forced to
look away from the screen hostile part 2
found the line poked it then jumped
right to the other side the movie ran
into problems well before it even made
its way into theaters the original
theatrical poster had to be banned and
replaced because it was too graphic it
simply featured a small bit of text
overlaid on an image of chopped up
bloody flesh the replacement poster had
an unclothed woman's body holding what
is presumably her own severed head so
that one likely ran into issues at most
theaters as well the stories such as it
is follows a group of art students on
Nation who unwittingly get auctioned off
to a Secret Ring of wealthy torture
Fanatics scene after scene of nudity and
torture play out including graphic
depictions of scalping multiple
beheadings and sever genitalia being fed
to dogs
saw took the World by storm in 2004.
horror fans were intrigued by the film's
grotesque premise and delighted by its
sudden twist ending a lot of the magic
has to do with James Juan's directing
which might be why there's little magic
or substance to be found in the sequels
when you start with a sadistic killer
dishing out punishment via elaborate
torture devices to anyone he deems
deserving it's hard to get much more
disturbing that didn't stop the saw
sequels from trying to up the ante and
even though the most squeamish of
viewers stopped after the first film
South 3 is the one that finally took
things too far there are of course all
the nightmarish traps that fans had come
to expect from the franchise a woman is
ripped apart after fishing a key out of
acid and still failing to escape another
is frozen to death and a man is drowned
in the ground up remains of pigs it's
all nauseating stuff but then the film
goes on to include a surgery scene in
which serial killer John Kramer has his
skull drilled open to relieve pressure
on his brain the movie is just one
miserable scene after another presented
with sloppy editing and a story that
would send an audience right to sleep if
it weren't for the constant onslaught of
nightmarish imagery on screen
a movie doesn't have to be gross or
crude to go too far sometimes the film
just finds a way to pour gas on a fire
that really needs to die down in 1991
Oliver Stone released his political
thriller JFK starring Kevin Costner and
Gary Oldman the film begins with the
investigation of Kennedy's assassination
which ends after Lee Harvey Oswald is
killed years later though the
investigation is reopened and a
conspiracy tying the murders to members
of the United States government itself
is uncovered we're going back into the
case Lou
murder of the president conspiracy
theories about the Kennedy assassination
have been running rampant since 1963 and
the most die-hard Believers didn't need
Stone to step in and reaffirm their
suspicions he decided to do it anyway
and JFK glorifies the kind of thinking
that keeps new conspiracy theories
popping up online every day in case
anyone thought that stone had just made
the poor decision to use real conspiracy
theories to spotter for a big movie he
came back and released a documentary
called JFK Revisited Through The Looking
class in 2021. it takes the same ideas
at the heart of the original film's plot
but presents them as though they are
definitive facts that stone himself is
uncovered
Zack and Miri Make a Porno like many
raunchy comedies is actually a sweet
movie when you get right down to it one
about lifelong best friends who may
actually have romantic feelings for one
another However the fact that it had the
word porno in its title meant the film
already went way too far for moviegoers
this was especially true in the movie's
marketing which kicked off with a poster
that proved so suggestive that it ended
up getting banned from theaters and
replaced with posters that seemed barely
related to the movie at all afterwards
the feature encountered further trouble
running TV ads and public billboards
with its full title resulting in it
being given the generic moniker of Zack
and Miri on many promotional materials
sometimes a movie that stirs up this
much controversy can ride the publicity
to box office success but that didn't
happen with this one if it's so easy how
come everybody doesn't do it because
other people have options and dignity
released at the very end of October 2008
Zack and Miri Make a Porno ended up
sinking Without a Trace at the bottom
box office the Kevin Smith comedy is
ultimately a film that wants to Target
your heartstrings but despite the racy
title it probably failed to catch your
attention
[Music]